we just learned how to make the raddest
eggplant parm and what's amazing is this
cookbook is about a sort of
matriculation a choose your own
adventure what you have left over then
becomes the next dish so we made
eggplant parm we have some sauce-less
dough
sauce left over and alexis is going to
show us what we can turn that into take
it away so we've spent all this time
making this amazing sauce and rather
than let it go to waste i mean you could
save it for
you know freeze it for a later day put
it on pasta but we're gonna make
um some saucy eggs and tomatoes which
just gets simmered on the stove and you
can actually i think you can come help
me if you actually want to dole this out
into like an even layer i'll dull it and
this this is such a like quick easy
amazing breakfast recipe so you can kind
of like you know make like four divots
four divots and then if you want to
actually help me just like crack
[Laughter]
[Applause]
alexis
do you remember when i told you i was
messy okay but i messy too i think it
was a collaborative effort it was i i
i just like proving my point sometimes
messes are made in the kitchen watch
this
[Applause]
and you know i like to add some cheese
you know if you're making eggplant parm
we've got some mozzarella left over and
you can just kind of like
add this
listen
my cookbook is called rebel homemaker
which i wrote with an incredible chef
paular valdez i'm also mad because i
screwed up that oh and
well okay the joy of this is that we're
not actually gonna eat this one because
we have a done one right here thank god
this is what it's gonna look like
[Applause]
i mean i like to add so i like to add
some cheese if you have it we're using
mozzarella you know just something that
gets nice and melty adds like a little
flavor element but you could also add
spinach you could add really whatever
you have in your pantry i love spinach
in the morning so i would totally green
this out but the the pepper and the
basil i i swear we can all be these
beautiful platers with garnish and
thoughtfulness plating is actually you
just need some herbs
garnish it changes i mean how do you
feel like
dipping bread dipped
in just i feel real good about it is how
i feel
oh my god
oh my god god i mean that sauce is
getting like cooked again it's like more
flavorful you've got the perfectly
cooked eggs
so it changes the
flavor profile i love it oh my god i'm
so excited that i got to do this with
you it's true
[Applause]
like
all of my
friends in the culinary world
we're freaking out that you are coming
on this show
so thank you and can we please do this
again i hope so and can i be messy
me too okay
you know how they say let's break bread
we can break eggs
perfect perfect all right thank you
alexis grab your copy of to the last
bite my new favorite cookbook available
now wherever books are sold
[Music]
you